tout part d'un simple coup de fil en
provenance de tunisie
un appel à l'aide face à la crise
sanitaire qui frappe le pays
submergé par le nombre de contaminations
et de décès bouleversé par cet appel
le docteur jemaa pris la décision d'agir
j'ai vu un appel aux dons pour la
tunisie n'a tunisien et je les appelais
je lui ai dit écoute on se réunit que
peut-on faire
et dans la même ambiance
lié à monsieur zitouni qui passe me voir
pour une consultation et je lui dis
monsieur zitouni le problème il est là
venus nous rejoindre et il m'a dit il
répondu favorable ont favorablement à
mon appel
on est allé sur place et là on a échangé
et on a dit que peut-on faire un autre
niveau
sos médecins et secouristes sans
frontières décide alors d'apporter leur
soutien au projet près d'un million de
masques du gel des fauteuils et un
concentrateur d'air ont été collectés et
rassemblés dans un local prêté par ce
gérant d'une entreprise d'ambulances lui
donner une ambulance brancards on avait
quand même que nos amis tunisiens
étaient très très très touché par locaux
vides
face à ça et sont très démunis ils ont
rien voilà donc pourquoi pas leur venir
en aide
comme mohamed zitouni la clinique
d'origène décide de participer au projet
et devient l'un des premiers donateurs
un geste naturel pour le directeur
médical
j'adhère pleinement cette participation
parce que la compassion c'est bien
mettre la compassion anact pour apporter
sur le terrain de laives c'est encore
mieux ce matériel finalement et pas
matérielles qui nous sera utile donc
autant qu'il soit utile à des gens qui
n'ont aujourd'hui besoin
au total quatre ambulances ont été
sollicités et partiront chargé de
matériel
toutes les autorisations ont été
accordées et les organisateurs ont mis
un point d'honneur à remettre en mains
propres les dons à l'association
tunisienne sur place les quatre
véhicules doivent quitter la bourgogne
ce mercredi